the gyro can experience some 10 days in
I think something like that Said's a
nice
so I'm 11 days in I started a couple of
days before and I've been eating nothing
but meat bacon steak helped me a lot of
extra fat if I eat the help me it was
like cholesterol son I don't know I got
my blood work done last Monday I'll get
the results back soon and then I'm gonna
do it again at the end of the month but
I've already lost seven pounds you feel
good you look good when he came out the
guys looking tight boys thing I lost my
belly I had a gut I was this is where I
get fat instantly right here it goes
right here and then it starts pushing
out I think all dudes do right I don't
know some people get in their face I get
in my face too
I feel it in my face when I'm washing my
face my smile totally I get him both
yeah but that's where you feel your face
right in my face if I smile you know the
shape of your face from you wash your
face every day so you get in there and
you like balances like West face also a
fat face is a bummer it's a bummer yeah
I'm that I've been ever like 190 but
here's the thing that's good about it
I'll tell you what's bad about it first
diarrhea is rough and eating only state
gets boring like diarrhea but the kinda
diary that I'm talking about is like
confusing it's like you gotta run like
you do not trust your butthole it's like
you know it's not telling you till the
front door it's not see the fire in the
horizon I warning you to get to the
bathroom
it's like the fire is at its making no
doorknob hot
what if yours what if you're starving up
you're far from home and there's a
Burger King and that's it there's a
Burger King for I'm just order for
whoppers and then I'll take the meat out
of them I'll just heat the meat okay
that's it yeah
I'm gonna do it for the whole month I
had an olive I guess I cheated a little
I have olive yeah you know I've had a
glass of wine here and there and I guess
that's you know but that's just drinking
for why did you decide to do it I want
to see what's up because I know a lot of
people that I respect that right like
Jordan Peterson in particular that guy's
a [ __ ] genius and when he's telling
me what a massive impact it's
cognitively he said that intellectually
he's at his prime he said all of his
immune system autoimmune issues went
away and I that's vitiligo is an
autoimmune issue so I'm seeing what
happens with that too but that isn't
really spreading any but with him he was
having gum issues receding gums that
went away his gums actually came back
didn't his daughter his daughter sick
too that's where they started she's got
serious arthritis like really bad but it
helped it right see this is what it is
it's an elimination diet so instead of
your diet breaking down a bunch of
different things it's just breaking down
one thing and this one thing that human
beings have been eating since the
beginning of time like this idea that
human beings are herbivores is pretty
much nonsense one of the main reasons
why we became what we are they think is
because we started eating meat we
started getting better access to protein
from cooking it because we figured out
how to harness fire and then through
hunting we started getting more devious
and started you know thinking and having
better critical skills and then eating
mushrooms I think all those things
that's just me taking supplements though
oh yeah yeah yeah cuz you have to write
again every no cuz I have a couple vegan
students that man once said I don't
listen to Jerry no more hater he talks
too much about meat he's like that's
that's your trigger it's Mexican Mexico
either
95 to 97% of the population of the
planet Earth eats meat this is what
vegans are it's very loud and very vocal
you know they want to make it look like
this is massive movement like no it's I
don't know you know I don't know what
your body feels like when you eat things
everybody's body is different
everybody's body reacts to nutrients
different SEP for processed foods we can
all agree that does not good for anybody
yeah processed sugar the reason why
people are so [ __ ] fat the reason why
everyone's so fat is carbohydrates and
fat and sugar and all that mixed up
together and mass
portions and sedentary lifestyle there's
a bunch of factors so I've killed a
bunch of those factors right I killed a
sedentary lifestyle exercise a lot I and
then I killed most of the sugar most of
the [ __ ] and then before I went on
this diet I had gotten off the rails a
little bit too many too many carbs too
much pasta I was eating like [ __ ]
subs fell apart dance super sobs no oh
son Ventura over at least I know hell
yeah oh you gotta give them a giant you
gotta get the giant pastrami the giant
pastrami holy [ __ ] is it good and it's
all bread fatty pastrami and look man
that's a lot of calories like you could
have run some campaign style type miles
to burn off that [ __ ] but so all the
different things that could [ __ ] with
your health and all the different things
they make what makes you feel good what
makes you feel bad depending upon your
biology your lifestyle I'm experimenting
you know yeah so this is my experiment
for the month just meat for the month so
far this is the most amazing thing I
would just no sorry sorry energy levels
like this straight there's no
fluctuations do cuz the carbs insulin
there's no carbs there's no carbs I'm
not having any car yeah I'm saying
before you're probably eating carbs or
some form of carb spike in your days
like this dude I would love I love pasta
it's so bad I would make like elk
sausage and a big bowl of spaghetti it's
so nice it's so good
in the moment but afterwards like the
amount of time that it feels good versus
the Valentine it doesn't feel good it's
so math so I hate myself afterwards I
hate my but the amount of time it feels
good it's like five minutes but goddamn
that's a good five it's a good it's a
great [ __ ] [ __ ] it [ __ ] with your hole
so does like the think of that think of
it this way how often would you wanna
get laid if every time we got laid you
gain 20 pounds you believe every time
I'm getting late I just keep me in fat
once a month then once a month yeah
just ride it out I got this unit a month
that's that weight down again start
looking fresh
get laid jerking off do you gain like
five pounds no you don't get anything
jerking off I I would have to see her
your boy might get fat she's been fine
what about if she's willing to [ __ ] you
while you're fat
that's a special girl special girl
doesn't get turned off at all by your
big fat gut don't give a [ __ ] she
doesn't care if you're gay now they're
out there they're out there they're out
there
chubby chances bro so I this is
obviously the Goldilocks period you know
like it's your also it's a it's a
honeymoon right I just started and
you're into it I don't know I don't know
what this is I think you know usually
about like 13 days in that's where
people break we like [ __ ] this dude or
I'm not feeling great it was really
boring about five days in but no like I
said now it was today the ninth
so today's eleventh day in today was no
problem I know what I'm doing my biggest
issue I put on weight especially in
December was the road because I do
whenever I get Philly its cheesesteaks
or New York it's Pete's just it's just
you know there's gonna be more
discipline it's late too because you
know you get done at 1:00 2:00 a.m. yep
that's up I gotta figure it out yeah
people did eat like this though there's
human beings that have eaten like this
for long periods of time like the idea
they didn't it's crazy like Inuit see
like this Native Americans the Comanches
a like this
Comanches barely ate anything other than
Buffalo
[Applause]